Well, the key to this problem is breaking it into parts.
This question really has two parts the way I see it.
First we have an energy part.
When I squeeze the spring, I'm adding elastic potential energy into our system.
When I let this go and release it,
that elastic potential energy is being converted to kinetic energy.
From that I should be able to find the velocity at which the mass leaves the table.
How do I do that?
I see that all of the potential energy--and this is the potential energy in a spring--
all gets converted to kinetic energy.
Solving out the algebra, which I've done in a few steps here,
tells me that the velocity with which it leaves the spring and therefore leaves the table
is equal to x * √(k / m).
Plugging in our values: x is 0.25 cm, remember--not meters--times √350/1.
But over 1 doesn't change anything, so a √350.
This gives me a velocity of 5.68 m/s.
Okay. Phase one of the problem is done.
Now we can just think of this problem as a block being thrown horizontally
with a velocity of 4.68 m/s.
Now we use our standard 2-dimensional motion skills to solve this.
First I want to calculate the time spend in the air.
Since there's no vertical velocity initially, my equation of motion simplifies to this.
There's no v₀t term this time.
I know Δy is equal to h, so manipulating this around--
moving the 2 up, dividing by g--I find t² is equal to 2h/g,
which means the time the object spends in the air is just the square root of that--
2h--h is 2 meters, so 2 * 2 is 4 over g, which is 10, gives me a time of 0.63 sec.
Now, well, I'm almost done.
We know that vertical and horizontal motion are independent in free fall.
We're moving at this constant velocity of 4.68 m/s horizontally for 0.63 sec.
So, d is just equal to this v₀ₓ now, the initial velocity in the x direction,
times this time, and when I plug in this numbers,
I get a distance of 2.96 or we'll just round it to 3 m.